Are So opposite because I've only
been in one fight in my life.
It was in ninth grade playing basketball
and it was against a dude named Matama.
Like I'll never forget,
his name is Matama Drake.
And I threw one punch and I hit him
right in the face and he looks at me and
goes, what's up? And I was,
oh no.
[inaudible] know.
Like, oh, we're good. Oh my God, you
get away with it. Oh yeah, we'd start
playing bass. Thank God. Like that was it.
Like literally I hit him as hard as
I could. I could take a shot. Oh.
And it was just like, what's up? I
was like, nothing. Nothing is up.
So that's the only time that you
back? No. Wow. No, cause I, I,
then I started, you know, oh you okay.
It's your ball man did not try to
get you back. I mean, and then I,
I was, there was a club in Houston named
power tools that I used to a gay bar. No,
w no, no, no. It to be right.
Yeah. It sounds like one
that was hardcore gay bars.
Houston,
the gay bar was called riches at the time,
but I worked at power
tools and I was a bouncer.
So that's when I was like
250 pounds, you know? Uh,
you are a lot bigger when I met you.
Oh yeah.
Cause I played college football for
Arkansas, so I played outside linebacker.
So I was just stop lifting weights
or do you still put a little bit? No,
I'm all cardio now because yeah,
like trainers,
any trainer I work with since I got a
big frame or like what puts him said no,
I want to stay lean. Right. You know,
but it's good for old age to man.
You don't want to have back problems in
44 years old now. Yeah. I'm a crazy dude.
Two time flies.
51 see what 55 zero two in is so scary
when you read stories about people just
dropping dead too, like around her age.
Luke Perry. That's what I'm saying.
Mason Lee my age. Well, they said what?
What is the danger zone is like
45 to 55 with heart failure.
It's like cry in. Oh Man.
Did I beat my body up.
I'm running that bitch until
the fuck his wheels fall off.
I'm always getting stem cell shots and
I'll fucking run in hills and lifting
weights. I still live
heavyweights retarded. Yeah.
Why don't you tell that word?
Set it again. Trying to get that rid
of that word out of my vocabulary.
It just comes out sometimes. Why?
Why are you still lifting weights?
Like heavy like that?
Like what does it do for you?
Well it does a bunch of things. First
of all, if you want to train Jujitsu,
it's very good to be strong. Yeah, it
makes a big difference. First of all,
for defense, especially for defense,
you know like for offense for sure too,
but really you want to
be able to defend you.
Like defending is you have to be strong
but also you just like being bigger.
It helps. Yeah, I like it. Yeah. I
like being able to pick up things.
I liked the physical ability of beans
for, I liked being in shape too. Yeah.
Like being able to run for long distances.
I like knowing that I
can go rounds on the bag,
like I'll do fives hard rounds
on the back so you can run it on.
My knees are messed up.
I can't like get on a treadmill and raw.
I can do like I've done the stem and
the knee and it's helped out a lot,
but I'm still that dude that's on,
I'm like on the super fortunate.
I'm super fortunate. My
knee injuries, I've had knee
injuries, but um, my meniscus,
I only had one meniscus scope on my
left knee and it wasn't terrible.
Like I was back to full 100% function
after that. And my right knee, I didn't,
I have a little baby tear that
I've got some stem cell shot into,
but I had both of them reconstructed.
Their ACL were replaced,
but I'm no problems. They work, they
work great. Yeah. See, I just need to,
I listened to you and I, it's like you
always taken something and I'm like, Oh,
I've got to find out what that is and
now just want to get in better shape.
I'm in shape, but I, it's when you get
older it's just like tough. It is just,
it just key is writing it down
like you have to do it. Like do,
do you keep a daily schedule
off? Shit, you have to do it? No,
I just wake up and go.
I do have, I wake up,
I work out like a cardio workout
and then I do infrared sauna,
which has changed my life.
Changed Your Life, right?
Every morning I infrared sauna for now.
It's the best.
You sweat all that shit out.
You're like, you feel great.
Your skin glistens like I think it's
actually like changed the game for me.
I have more energy now. Everything's
better. It's so good for your body.
They did a study that showed
a 40% decrease in mortality,
mortality amongst all causes,
heart attack, stroke, cancer,
40% decrease with people that were
doing the sauna four times a week. Well,
I will tell you this because the whole
thing is everybody wants to feel young
and when you were young,
the thing you did most of sweat and I
feel like when I sweat, it just it's,
it feels,
I don't know,
I just feel good sweating because he
reminds me of when I played sports.
It reminds me even though I'm
not doing on the, you know,
I sweat a little on the treadmill,
but when I do that infrared,
it makes me feel great. Mom, I think
there's a bunch of shit going on,
but there's that. Yeah, for
sure. Like it's good to feel
good, like you're sweating,
but there's heat shock proteins.
Your body actually produces
anti inflammatory properties.
It's really good for you.
It's really good for joint aches
and all kinds of like this.
I used to think of the song as
being nonsense. Like what do you,
what do you fucking lane in
the Sauna for liquidity doing?
They're just getting hot school workout,
post workout.
What kind of sauna do you do though?
I do a regular song. Okay. Super Hot.
Regular Simon telling you you need to
try the infrared. It's Ken. Yeah. I mean,
but look, it's all just about
getting your body, Huh? Yeah.
Like it's good to try to infrared.
I'm sure. I'm sure it works great.
But this study, the 40%
decrease in mortality, that
was with a regular storm saw.
Okay. Yeah. That's why I got a
regular sauna because a doctor,
Rhonda Patrick told me that,
okay,
the studies that have been done have all
been done with a regular sauna and she
said there might be some
benefit for infrared on it,
but I don't know what's published. What
is, see if there's a benefit. See if this,
they can say what's the benefit
to infrared cooking my organs.
I don't even know it.
No, I don't think so. No,
I think it's great for just feel amazing
afterwards. Supposedly what happens,
right? It gets deeper in
your tissue or something.
Like it's supposed to go deeper inside.
I remember I was texting back and forth.
I was like, you gotta like if you do
the infrared sauna for like a week,
it's a game changer. It just
is too. So I don't know.
I would like you to try regular sauna to,
how hot does the infrared get?
A like 140 140 minutes by heating the air
though too. It's a difference. It's not,
it doesn't heat the air.
It's like you walk in and it feels,
it doesn't feel like it's that, but that's
just weird. That's your microwave shit.
None of that, man. It's like hot pockets.
Can you turn them into a hot pocket?
That's what I'm saying. I probably
burned it up all my organs right now,
but I don't know. I love it. I like
coming in and feeling that superheat.
You go in there and you're
like, oh, it feels so good.